there has been a ton of press around
Donald Trump's interview with George
Stephanopoulos on ABC News last week and
I already talked a lot about the
politics in the interview the things
Trump said the incorrect allegations and
assertions that Donald Trump made but
there is a 4747 second section of this
interview that isn't getting nearly the
discussion it deserves which exposes
what I consider to be the real Donald
Trump the truly terrible toxic bad
person that Donald Trump is to be around
and this is kind of buried in part three
of the interview with George
Stephanopoulos what ABC News did is
divided the interview into three parts
the first two I think are each about 12
or 13 minutes long and part three at
least as I saw it divided up on the ABC
News YouTube channel is much shorter and
in part three George Stephanopoulos is
pressing Donald Trump about his
financial disclosures and Trump is going
into one of these nonsense talking point
rants that he gaves which are never
really answers they often contradict the
thing he says in the first 15 seconds
contradicts the thing he says in the
second 15 seconds he says he won't
release his financial disclosure but he
hopes that eventually people see it even
though he could release at any time and
in the midst of Donald Trump talking
about this there's a coffin the
background okay and Trump stops talking
and the look on his face changes he
looks all of a sudden rabid and he says
he wants to do it over again because his
chief of staff is coughing in the
background now it's actually pretty
interesting that ABC News even included
this in the final cut because Trump
asked for it to be redone and then he
redoes his answer with equally
nonsensical talking points but when you
hear him talking about the cough in the
background when you see the look on his
face when you hear the vitriol and the
toxicity in his voice Trump sounds like
he thinks the people around him
including his chief of staff who cough
are just worthless barely human forms of
life and this is the Trump we've thought
was the real Trump from all of the
reports about him from former employees
former campaign officials from reports
about his relationships with his own
families his own family members
with his various mistresses and women
he's had affairs with the audio tells us
a lot it's better if you're watching
this so that you also see the anger and
the disgust on Donald Trump's face
someone coughing this is a brief
appearance of the real Donald Trump
which I believe Trump didn't think would
ultimately be published as part of the
interview but still if you're even
willing to treat people like this in
front of George Stephanopoulos and an
entire ABC crew plus your own staff and
security how is he behaving in more
truly private settings take a look at
these 47 seconds of video much much
bigger much much better than anybody
thereafter my financial statement the
Senate they'd like to get my financial
statement at some point I hope they get
it you're gonna turn it over no at some
point I might but at some point up they
get it cuz it's safe enough it's a
fantastic financial statement it's a
fantastic financial statement and let's
do that over he's coughing in the middle
of my answer yeah okay I don't like that
you know your chief of staff you gotta
cough please just to change the shine
sorry okay you want to do that a little
differently there so at some point so at
some point I look forward to frankly I
want I'd like to have people see my
financial statement there's a literal
Jekyll and Hyde transformation that you
see on Donald Trump's face when Mulvaney
coughs Trump stops playing the character
that he's playing in the interview and
he becomes the real Trump and by the way
what does it even mean that it's a
financial statement that's fantastic and
if it's so good why isn't Trump going to
publish it that that's a whole other
discussion to be had but this is the
real Trump he is a terrible person he
has no empathy for anyone period he's
horrible to be around he's self-centered
to the absolute maximum he could have
indicated that he didn't like the COFF
and he wanted to do it over by saying
sorry George one second Mick are you
okay and done it over again any non
narcissist would have behaved completely
differently here and this is one of the
most disturbing parts of the interview
as Donald Trump sits there with pure
in his eyes for his own chief-of-staff
it was actually suggested and this makes
it even more interesting it was
suggested that Trump was making such a
fool of himself with his answer on this
financial disclosure issue to George
Stephanopoulos that Mulvaney might have
coughed deliberately to ruin what Trump
was saying because it was so stupid and
dumb in order to give Trump and out and
if that's true and we don't know if it
is that would actually make Donald
Trump's treatment of Mulvaney a-- even
more stunning even though it wouldn't
surprise me that Donald Trump simply
wouldn't be smart enough to realize that
Mulvaney was trying to help Trump and
trying to get him out of trouble in any
case that's the real Donald Trump that
is the real Donald Trump who is an
absolute disgrace and nightmare to work
for expose very briefly in 47 seconds of
audio and video I encourage you to watch
the entire interview because the whole
thing is a pathetic gong show